I wake up sleep eat wake up sleep eat
having a party last time we went outside
it was snowing that was on the 14th of
March there's been a lot of eating a lot
of cooking a lot of baking since we've
been in lockdown
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Susie and I am from a
Township called Alexandra in South
Africa the biggest changed during the
lockdown in my life is the fact that my
schedule is no longer the same my
routine is no longer the same I cannot
spend time with my friends go out enjoy
and see people a lot it has always been
just spending a day in a home and it's
and getting feds which is very bad for
my health
[Music]
[Music]
is trying to do it without twin suns the
outside connected nature and make sure
that they are in an environment where
they can learn really which they can do
here any farmers tracks in the rice
fields we see that everything is bright
and shiny and it's it's really spring it
has started I live work and study in
Moscow where I rent an apartment with my
mom and we have been on some reservation
since the 15th of March it's hard to see
the forest from our window
a real proper forest in which we cannot
take any walks the birds outside and if
you can hear that dawn chorus is going
on
absolutely beautiful love it we're quite
spoiled we live in the countryside and
we've got a garden I hate to think what
logged I was like for people who live in
a flat in the middle of a city hi there
my name is Giles Taylor my day job is
I'm a paramedic I'm just about to go to
work 12 hours on an ambulance primarily
gonna be dealing with people who carried
almost certainly there's not many sort
of probably called normal jobs at the
moment so Neil's gonna go in and have a
lock so he's just getting dressed up now
I don't like coming home and feeling
dirty because I've been around people
and I don't like bringing that sort of
thing home to my family I'm here at the
radio I'm waiting to go in for the show
I'm Frankie muslin I am a musician from
Tanzania as you can see this is what I
do what I'm out and I've sanitized my
hands already it's not official that we
are on lockdown but most of us are
locked you know our house is working for
more
yeah cuz we're all scared I even scared
of my own car if like somehow inside of
it there is like teeny tiny corner
biases for me was some very very tough
week so go into work feeling that I was
in danger all the time but most of all
feeling and thinking that my mom was in
danger because I moved around the city I
went mad with washing hands and stuff
like that when I was at work but then on
the 15th of March we decided not to go
anywhere and I was thinking of actually
going asking for our vacation at work I
am waiting to go back to work I waiting
for a TV production but we can't film so
until then I'll be working from home a
little bit but chilling out here with my
mum there's been a lot of eating a lot
of cooking a lot of baking since we've
been in lockdown there was also a
thousand-piece puzzle done in our house
and I've usually sort of organised some
sort of video catch up with a friend
[Music]
this used to be the part of the house
repented I guess that's an extinct being
now this is my new workplace in the game
in the night
it's party time yeah we have zoo parties
house parties and maybe because it's
closest to the internet because of data
and network this online learning makes
it even harder to make we are not
allowed to even go back to school or
Residential's at school
times that way okay well that's just in
one way first
I'm homeschooling which is a little bit
different for me something had eight
equals thirty-two so what's the
something not totally certain how good I
am I can point them in the direction of
the online stuff that the teachers have
given which is great but yeah as much as
as far as helping garrow's and being a
teacher you know it's not my forte
although Ally says they have good one I
do I was good at English I'm good at PE
this is probably one of the more
exciting parts of the day during luck
dad keep getting out of the half and
into the getting some fresh air okay
I've got this mess of park right by my
house everyone's really good here at
keeping their distance they force you
know stay at least 2 meters from you
even when it's really busy
a typical day in lockdown right now is
normal it doesn't even show whether it's
lockdown or it's just a normal day
without this pandemic I must say the
level of soldiers and police going
around the streets has decreased and
people are starting to take advantage of
bed it's very scary for me that I'm
quite comfortable in for selfish elation
I don't feel that I need miss out a lot
I feel like this life is comfortable I
get to study I get to research I get to
do my work and since I'm obsessed with
my work and my studies this this just
works perfectly and this is the wrong
thing for 25 year old to say social
interaction that's going to be the same
for most people we have we have a cafe
and it's incredibly sociable
so yeah it's it's tough oh I miss
performing live I miss singing and
dancing with people we're ready I'll
just do many concerts by yourself at my
house when all this is over I would
really love to go and hug all the family
and friends that I haven't seen and you
know go to a restaurant and sit down
with them have a meal have wine or beer
and you know sit closer then the two
meters and I think that's the the one of
the main things I've missed the most to
the birds they are so noisy so I guess
with no but you should the garden the
air is pure the garden is beautiful
the sky is good and this is the edge of
my little world
[Music]